messieurs bonsoir cela ça se passe est
aujourd'hui en grande bretagne un
anglais sur deux à deux pas du pelleter
pour retrouver sa voiture même parfois
vous l'avez vu pour dégager de pau
ventes ont construit sous la neige
en france on n'a pas atteint le même
niveau d'engourdissement mais au nord de
la loire la situation a mis du temps à
se déjouer il ya d'abord le verglas qui
a rendu pas rendre dangereux concepteurs
routier du nord et de la picardie
près de 50 voitures se sont percutées ce
matin sur l'autoroute lille armentières
sept blessés légers
bon nombre de poids lourds ont été
bloqués plusieurs autres voilà je vous
parle aussi d'amour un terrain dus à la
neige dans le vaucluse des avions
détournés de roissy ce matin sur les
aéroports voisins de l'effondrement de
centaines de pylônes ppp en
seine-et-marne et ailleurs des
inondations menacent de l'interruption
du ramassage scolaire bougre village de
l'est et enfin et surtout de l'étonnant
spectacle que réservé aux caméras de
philippe gassot et michalak la blancheur
immaculée de la nova dis donc
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas le jour idéal
pour aller revoir ça drôle
depuis trois jours les méconnaissable
grand chelem est suspendu aux fils
électriques jusqu'à présent on ne
déplore aucune victime
seulement des dégâts énormes figé et
paix qui craque
d'activité comme les mains engourdi
on attend avec résignation il en a fallu
des coïncidences pour arriver à cette
calamité jamais vu depuis la guerre de
la neige du froid et de la pluie si
froide elle il est resté accroché aux
arbres et aux fils électriques qui se
sont réalisés sur quoi il est trop tôt
pour faire le bilan
on en reste à l'étonnement devant cette
féerie destructrice ce sont les
personnes âgées qui souffrent le plus
des asiles ont été évacués mais pour les
vieux qui restent seuls chez eux
l'inquiétude est grande de mandat
j'allais chercher un morceau bout en
algérie avec le verglas est tombé puis à
l'enjeu du rosm casse une jambe ou vous
sentez isolé c'est la trahison
heureusement du monde
on attend
les éleveurs ne savent plus à quel saint
se vouer
vous continuez à nourrir les poules est
par exemple les fermiers ont besoin
d'électricité et d'eau pourtant il ne
faut pas compter de réparation avant
huit jours
si tout va bien actuellement les poules
sont dans l'obscurité
ce qui après des réussites et donc elle
ne mange presque pas la plante droite on
va leur retomber à peut-être à moitié
dans quelques jours l'important lui si
la lumière ne revient pas avant lui jour
on pourra toucher d'aliments ou pas du
port d'alimentation pour d'autres c'est
pour vous allez tous à vous voyez avec
le système la culture moderne
industriels
tout marche à l'électricité super on
peut bien hébreu et un état major du
froid fonctionne 24 heures sur 24 les
ouvriers de la voirie les pompiers les
gendarmes multiplient les interventions
quant aux habitants des cinq mineurs
privés dans tout ils ont fait un bond de
50 ans en arrière ce qui concerne le
chauffage malcho pas me lamenter
chauffage on a quoi la foule arrive à
chauffer quand même les filles étaient à
coup la lumière
c'est bon ça je ne pense pas que ça va
être rétablie aujourd'hui ça peut être
est un fléau lui non enfin la roadmap du
jeu ça s'est plaint et la sortie du
moulin 4 or les choses dans le temps la
situation est sérieuse on est passé tout
à côté du drame auquel peugeot en
normandie on commencera wyss la ville
rue d'où nous arrive progressivement du
sud ouest c'était très sensible
aujourd'hui dans la région parisienne et
cela devrait continuer demain les
températures maximales sur le temps au
sensible il fera quand même assez froid
dans l'extrême nord-est avec des jaunes
et un rouge et en alsace et puis en fin
de journée il pleuvra voisinage de
l'atlantique et il fera assez beau dans
le midi méditerranéen
vous n'avez pas vu parce qu'on ne les
cachais conseil interministériel ce
matin plus exempt un conseil central de
planification destiné à débroussailler
un dossier qui sera débattue demain en
conseil des ministres ce dossier par
dossier douloureux c'est celui de la
sécurité du travail
il ya encore trop d'accidents chaque
année en france il est souvent qui
pourraient être évités jadis on espérait
que tous les travaux pénibles sur un
jour exécutive et aujourd'hui on
constate qu'on ne m'entend pas besoin
d'en faire faire tout ce qui est
dangereux parfois l'homme qui travaille
doit prendre un risque parce que son
geste
qui devient danger et malgré les
précautions cette source-là accident du
travail n'est malheureusement pas près
de se tarir
en 75 du bénin plus d'un million d'accès
râle 3 500 morts c'est tout de même
difficile à l'épreuve dans une société
depuis décembre 76 une loi nouvelle
impose aux entreprises une sécurité
accrue surtout pour les travailleurs
manuels et diverses mesures de
prévention envie insuffisante à l'époque
quand le nombre aux parlementaires c'est
cette loi qui va être complété par les
orientations présentées demain au
conseil des ministres par monsieur black
au programme d'abord l'essentiel
l'amélioration des positions rang et
salariés affectés à des travaux
dangereux coup paiement
ils sont nombreux et puis la médecine
grave
il s'agit non pas de modifier son statut
et de renforcer ses moyens en matière de
prévention il sera aussi question de
formation de l'enseignement de cette
médecine phare et aussi de la recherche
dans ce domaine
et puis les conséquences des accidents
et des maladies professionnelles que
l'on n'a pas pu éviter les textes prévus
améliore la démonisation et aussi la
réinsertion des travailleurs a réuni à
voir en forme vaste campagne
d'information tous ouvriers ont dont je
vais mais aussi pdj responsable autre
gros chapitre du conseil de demain la
préparation du budget soit sanguine
le gouverneur de la banque de france
c'est valéry giscard d'estaing
aujourd'hui monsieur b remarque qu'après
coup le franc se portait bien
quant à raymond barre qui recevait qui
fait horreur reçu aussi par le public il
a déploré la faiblesse du dollar
journée d'action pour l'emploi organisé
aujourd'hui à paris par la cgt 5000
militants environ ont distribué des
tracts aux passants et leur ont présenté
parfois avec humour les difficultés de
leur entreprise fin d'après midi une
délégation se sont réunis à la maison de
la métallurgie pour assister à un
meeting au cours duquel henri tilhet
notamment protester contre
l'implantation à l'écouté du sinn
français encore une carte de plus ça
peut avoir dans votre portefeuille
une carte d'identité médical sur cette
carte
un numéro de téléphone le médecin qui
vous traitera d'urgence l'occasion pour
rappeler afin de sa valeur à 2 contre
indication pour les remèdes qu'il entend
vous donnez aux initiatives qui
intervient au moment où l'ordre
accueille son 100.000e adhérents et oui
déjà plus de cent mille médecins en
france mais que de changer l'image
traditionnelle du praticien de table et
le profil du nouveau médecin généraliste
- sur le sens à venir autrefois chaque
village avait son docteur pour chaque
village avait son curé mais si l'on
reprend un total les médecins eux se
sont multipliés à saint-renan le docteur
lucas 40 ans de médecine
le malade a dû tricot faire alors
aujourd'hui peu de villages attente
encore leur médecin et jeunes
généralistes doivent se battre chez nous
quoi des clients comme tout le monde
véritable on a pu la situation
présidente que l'on avait autrefois mais
sur le plan financier mais sur le plan
de la notabilité en fait quand elle ne
monte pas au médecin que l'amiante est
le rival de m
urgent qu'on sentait cherche associés
médecine générale en vue succession
actuelle et 93 km de paris pour bon
cabinet prix à débattre quand vous
répondez un petit annoncé que vous vous
présenter quel genre de questions post
on pas déjà on me dit qu'elle est à 8 et
9 personnes qui attendent donc aprem de
joie qui sont atteints qui propose la
situation on me demande ce que j'ai fait
en général on me demande si j'ai fait
mon service militaire qu on la faisait
surtout si j'ai une certaine expérience
médicale pour magath fait deux ans que
je place ma part on me demande pas plus
on me demande évidemment si si
j'aimerais faire mon métier
et si j'ai de l'argent on en vient vite
l'argent très vite flou généralistes
sont simplement poche doit descendre de
son piédestal
il faut s'installer ou acheté une
clientèle problèmes pratiques n'ont pas
été préparés les lommoises étions en
vase clos
renfermé hospitalier ils seront dix
mille cette année a quitté la faculté la
concurrence aura douze cantons plus que
par conformisme ou par peur des risques
les médecins s'installent dans majorité
près du vieux de leur empreinte de
départements ça tuerait la seine les
hauts lieux de grandes facultés paris
montpellier
alors on en manque en eure et loir il
dans le nord avec un peu plus de
réalisme qu'ils peuvent acquérir ici
dans l'outrance de gibert à l'isq leur
problème serait moins grave
on évolue maintenant avec radar
nationale 2
de toute façon d'animer son
l'information et des revenus qui n'a pas
trop d'inquiétude à se faire par rapport
à une crise très importante ailleurs
mais il raconte j'ai visé un certain
nombres de sécurité il doit être reçue
et mobile doit certainement être plus
mobile il doit certainement être moins
individualiste pour que derrière il va
parle beaucoup plus attention quand même
aux professionnels des autres
professions de son âme à être beaucoup
plus intégrée au problème de la
collectivité est à ce prix là c'est
certainement on appelle un cadre
supérieur qui n'est pas en voie
d'extinction
parce qu'il le métier les médecins on
peut aussi en train de changer
le médecin isolé seul face à ces malades
ni vision qui tend à s'estomper métier
ses soucis contaminé deux groupes pour
partager les regardons y obtenir une
qualité de la vie et rendre service aux
patients en offrant un même lieu général
aux dix premières spéciales mais la
rendre compte encore évoluer pour
certains il faut développer la
prévention prévenir la maladie plutôt
que la guérir je crois que les médecins
consacre tous une partir de leur temps à
faire de l'éducation sanitaire et social
une partie raisonnable de leur temps à
actualiser leurs connaissances et une
partie a soigné des jeunes alcar y aura
toujours des malades une fonction
technique essentiel que je crois que là
il y aura une bien meilleure utilisation
de tous ces jeunes médecins en tous les
cas on évitera des chômeurs on évitera
les affameurs chômeurs car en 1980 il y
aura 150 mille salles à fameux soit en
termes médicaux qui pousse à la
consommation car la tentation sera
grande pour un médecin de multiplier les
inutiles et quand le docteur vos plats
remet sa clientèle à un jeune confrère
que peut-il bien lui donner comme
conseil ce métier a évolué il est encore
à l'aube de profondes réformes
sur place des médecins salariés une
sélection à l'entrée de l'université la
profession nigga favorable alors
développer la prévention encouragé les
ménages s'installent dans des zones
déshéritées
de toute façon l'évolution de cette
profession est thomas du pouvoir
politique car il ne faut pas l'oublier
les médecins ont pour principe est la
sécurité sociale il affaires étrangères
maintenant toujours pas d'un coup le
corps de christian parce que j'aime
français détenus par les rebelles
tchadiens depuis le 18 janvier
kramer viennent de se rentre à l'instant
à lagos au nigeria pour essayer de
savoir ce qui se passe propose
maintenant un document le premier
concours seront sur un conflit
impossible de filmer la guerre entre
cambodgiens et vietnamienne nous avons
tout fait pour y aller pour essayer de
savoir ce qui s'y passe rien
aussi avons-nous pris ce soir la
responsabilité que vous le retrait ces
images tournées par les vietnamiens et
commentée en français par des
vietnamiens demande donc un certain
recul par rapport à la nation de les
recevoir
je me demande si quelques précautions
car ce document est assez fort très dur
même
lors de leurs affaires que dans quelques
mois en territoire vietnamien
les forces armées du camp poussière ont
commis les crimes les superbes
ils ont tout brûlé au portillon nous
tuer ou des centaines de maisons ont été
réduites en cendres en une seule mais
les actes de destruction de la partie
campe ou siens sont déroulés non pas
dans une seule région où une seule
province au nombre de deux depuis leurs
bourgs et des villages du vietnam situé
le long d'une frontière c'est tendance
et plus d'un millier de kilomètres de
puissalicon forces américaines ont été
ravagés par la paire que les aveux des
membres des forces armées du camp
pompiers qui ont participé aux
opérations d'encaissement en territoire
birman on coupe la commande et de
navigation de l'attaquant qui a maintes
fois prétendu que le cockpit ya n'a
jamais violé la terre ferme les eaux
territoriales ou l'espace aérien du
vietnam et que le peuple tient à faire
de ce salon un été et qui ont été fait
correctement dans les provinces
frontalières tout en se livrant à
l'incendié des maisons aux viols des
femmes aux clients désirent début et
d'autres bien au meurtre viol et dans
chaque hameau les forcenés du conflit
ont commis des mains aux vietnamiens
ces deux vastes étendues et dans des
régions populeuses
quinze minutes 3 secondes
tous ces hommes qui relève d'une
proximité des frontières avait déclaré
alors vous comprenez les opérations de
violation du territoire vietnamien
oui je vous rappelle qu'un commentaire
nous in et vient de dire que pour voir
le cambodia c'est donc le cambodge
alors paul nahon ce conflit on en parle
bien peu pour un idiot depuis très
longtemps
oui ce conflit entre le vietnam et le
combo dickens séculaire mais qui portait
à l'origine comme tout conflit
d'ailleurs su agen même de trêve sur les
problèmes de territoires hérités de
l'époque coloniale de l'époque française
et pepsico pas l'oublier cette vieille
haine que vouent depuis très longtemps
les cambodgiens et les vietnamiens lors
ce conflit territorial sur un tacle
apaisé pendant tant d'années pendant
toute américaine au vietnam en asie
il fallait à ce moment là que les
cambodgiens et le vietnamien se serre
les coudes pas problème entre eux depuis
que la perte quasi l'étang de thau
les vietnamiens ont repris leurs taux
bas avec l'atrocité que vous avez pu
compter sur ces images
mais il faut dire aussi que les forces
en présence sont un petit coup d'arrêt
oui les forces en présence sont très
inégales de dtv l'armée vietnamienne
d'après ce qu'on sait on dit même prêt
sous sur 1 million 250 mille hommes en
armes une arme est extrêmement moderne
un ex-officier bon écoutez vous avez
l'armée cambodgienne d'après ce qu'on en
sait aussi claude choses au maximum 200
milles 1 259
je crois que le plus important il faut
bien comprendre que à travers ses gerbes
france sont bien d'origine pas que 90 2
communisme qui s'affrontent d'un côté
vous avez les cambodgiens soutenu par le
régime de pékin de l'autre vous avez le
régime vietnamien à neuss lui aider le
tout le temps dans le régime
avec cette proportion vaut mieux que la
situation n'est donc voila comme la
vendre une semaine après le drame la
nique aux il vraiment chypriote ou
cypriote comme vous voudrez a refusé de
livrer à l'egypte les deux assassins ben
youssef sebaï la rame
ils ne sont pas et égyptien
dans chypriote il doit donc être jugé
ici ce sont les deux hommes qui sont à
l'origine du drame de l'aéroport de
larnaca et nous en arrivons à la
politique comme celui dont 185 candidats
pour 491 place au palais bourbon
les chiffres sont définitifs ce soir et
vous voyez que cette longue campagne
loin d'avoir abrité les aspects les
aspirants députés
même chose pour les téléspectateurs que
l'on disait lacets ceinture est
politique mais qui ont regardé en masse
notre débat d'hier soir complet avec
europe 1 georges marchais contraint à
faire craquer on ne peut pas dire que
les hommes étaient de l'assumer ils se
sont empoignés avec véhémence mercredi
et bien ce sera monsieur koné qui sera
l'invité de cartes sur table aujourd'hui
c'est à nouveau de sondages qu'il faut
parler d'un sondage sofres que publiera
demain 50% pour la gauche 45% pour la
majorité car ne bouge pas beaucoup mais
ce qui est peut-être plus apercevoir à
l'inde humaine c'est l'état des forces
en présence dans chaque camp oui bah à
l'intérieur du condat majorité des
petits glissements de l'ain points et
deux supplémentaires pr2 un point en
moins au détriment de divers majorité en
fait n'a pas un très grand sens en
pratique en revanche à gauche c'est
évident que le fait que le pc
proviennent à la barre des 21 % vous
savez que la cei pour cent c'est le
chiffre qu'a été avancée par georges
marchais comme le minimum pour un
désistement éventuel pour le second tour
donc là naturellement seuils records car
cela dit je crois vraiment pas ce qui
compte gelé tous et d'abord le rapport
des forces a relevé que la majorité au
premier tour et là il est clair que la
gauche a une avance qui est très
difficile à remonter pour la majorité
avant l'élection oui et d'autre part le
problème du second tour et de reports de
voix requis alors là est plus compliqué
alors comment ça se passait j'imagine
une certaine discipline en majorité
comme un vrai passionné de politique si
vous voulez au premier tour pour le
premier tour c'est la gauche qui a une
avance et on dit ainsi toute chance de
rattraper la 5ème au second tour en
revanche à l'intérieur de la majorité il
ya une discipline qui est inhabituel
bientôt mobilisation très grand puisque
neuf sur dix déjà les électeurs dans la
majorité qui soit rpr udf ou divers
majorité sont déjà de toute façon décidé
à voter pour le candidat de la majorité
à nos principes qui bénéficie d'un
pistolet automatique
c'est la majorité qui est un avantage et
ce qui va déterminer réellement le
résultat des élections puisque chacun
des deux camps à un point en fait en ce
sens à son avantage ça va être le
problème du report des voix à
l'intérieur le sens que à gauche et chez
les électeurs socialistes et chez les
électeurs communistes
de toute façon on est prêt à voter moins
bien qu'en 1973 pour le candidat de
l'autre la disa n'est pas une situation
figée et en réalité tout faux départ à
plein de la position que le pc puisque
le psg a dit que de toute façon il
ferait voter pour les candidats
communistes les mieux placés donc ça
dépendra largement de la position du pc
vous n'êtes pas parce qu'on peut quand
même imaginer ce que sera la position du
pc entre les lutteurs écouter et non
justement je suis pas devin il ya
plusieurs possibilités si vous voulez il
ya deux possibilités qui sont simples
avec des conséquences simple puis il ya
les possibilités plus complet les deux
possibles en clair simple c'est soit ce
que georges marchais appellerait un bon
désistement dire qu'ils décident
d'appliquer la discipline républicaine
car dans ce cas là il était blanc
pirates oui la gauche comme ça toujours
été le cas
ou bien alors au contraire il ya un
refus désistement le maintien du
candidat communiste donc forcément trois
candidats pour le second tour de la
majorité était pratiquement sûr de
l'emporter contre le veut il ya encore
quelques hypothèses éventuelle par
exemple de la part des communistes un
retrait sans désistement ou bien des
désistements sélectif ou bien tout
simplement des désistements revêche si
vous voulez des désistements vincent est
alors dans ce cas là il sait pas ce qui
peut se passer en deux hypothèses une
faveur de la gauche
une favorable à la majorité et entre ya
deux possibilités
eh bien puisque vous êtes un spécialiste
son match d'adieu mais je vous donne
celui là tu vois ce qu'il faut c'est un
pari bon lecteur londonien pour
l'instant quatre contre cinq
il donne la victoire de l'actuelle
majorité tout au long de ce boîtier nous
avons essayé de mettre en lumière ce que
l'on attend les petits partis il nous
reste à vous montrer les écologistes un
moment où le collectif écologiste moins
de dix-huit présente sa patronne
pour les élections 170 candidats de
toutes tendances
avec toujours le verre au coeur 170
candidats qui se veulent disons la
mauvaise conscience de tous les partis
nous voyons ici leur conférence de
presse
cent soixante dix c'est peu al'inverse
les partis traditionnels les écologistes
n'aime pas être candidat dans certains
groupes et la même ça lui désigné
d'office le plus jeune tirés au sort
mais tous avaient une sorte de programme
commun à savoir deux principes de fond
et une stratégie l'arête civils ou
militaires et celles l'arrêt de la
croissance aveugle tjx si l'on veut
c'est l'indépendance totale la vie des
artistes dire aucun désistement au
second tour facile et demain mais les
écologistes ont bien de rester à l'écart
et clivages politiques
d'abord en raison de leur succès aux
législatives de 1973 ils n'ont que deux
candidats c'est en alsace présidentielle
on y voit bien 2,2 pour ce baraquement
municipal il remonte à 10 % dans les
grandes droit aujourd'hui il pèse 2 3 à
5 % suivant les sondages le report de
ses voix au deuxième tour est l'une des
très grandes inconnues de ces élections
les icaunais ce sont les objectifs sont
totalement indépendant par rapport aux
partis politiques indépendants par
rapport à la droite comme par rapport à
la gauche
les joints et les autres sont totalement
les français et qui concerne d'abord et
avant tout les quotidiens bien du mal
aussi avec l'arrêt du nucléaire
tous sont d'accord là dessus mais
divergent quant aux moyens certains
défavorable au désistement en faveur de
candidats de partis traditionnels qui
aurait pris formellement l'engagement de
lutter contre l'atome et que les 78 bien
mal à rester une grinçant que les jeux
sont purs et durs et pour beaucoup ces
élections sont un mauvais moment à
passer
on a ras le bol de la politique on en a
marre de ces élections on n'y comprend
rien on ne voulait surtout pas rassemblé
ses partenaires comment est ce qu'on
peut faire de la politique
comment est ce qu'on peut faire sans
être obligée d'aller se faire tuer
malville cet été ou des ressembler aux
partis politiques représentant des
élections c'est ça qu'on cherche
voilà là daniel grandclément que nous
accueillons avec plaisir cette réaction
aquamit comme un petit lapsus et de 1,22
% de voix qu'il fallait par led pour
rené dumont en soi sans cap ça l'est
aussi depuis hier nous avons entamé
humain ses rangs semaine sur ce qui peut
bien sûr que peut bien penser une petite
ville moyenne française de tout ce
remue-ménage l'élection petite ville
c'est chine ont vendu avec mme hussein
nous allons voir comment là bas on
conçoit l'affrontement majorité
opposition que plus simplement on
baptisa chine à la guerre de la droite
et de la gauche
moi je cross se marquer fortement série
madame est heureux comme pro défendent
une certaine qu un peu ce qui était
d'abord appliquée par mitterrand qui
garde des sceaux 54 55 mde en 58 ont
bien défendu les idées du général de
gaulle qui était comme de l'ours qui
prouve quand même que les politiques le
changement d'opinion c'est le joli même
qui reste sur nos gouvernements fin de
notre travail qui on pouvait pas avoir
d'idées politiques contenu que un jour
fallait buts ont préservé des pieds
noirs ou quatre jours après le tout
raconté j'ai des algériens contre les
monnaies de loi s et c'est là vraiment
qu'on apprend peser le pour et le contre
il en reste pas grand chose si vous
voulez des quelques souvenirs vous
enlevez je veux dire dans votre tête
dans votre détermination bien on essaye
d'être le plus politique raconte
justement quand on est aussi bien les
idées de gauche que j'ai d'être droite
et qui après tout on n'a pas en main non
complaisante encore fait
posez deux des principaux éléments
passionnante de l'équation politique la
droite d'un côté la bouche de l'eau eau
j'en admet qu'il existe de part et
d'autre des gens dans tir de soi voilà
l'image qu'ils se font d'eux mêmes maths
et des eaux
en france on and on a l'habitude de
classer les gens droite pas dire grand
chose il ya des gens qui ont du coeur
qui sont sensibles et puis lé champion
qui sont intelligents qui ont de la
raison qu'ils pensent à l'intérêt
général
la gauche la gauche ce sont des intérêts
particuliers
mais ce sont ses clients qu'ils pensent
surtout à l'intérêt des individus qui
doit avant tout l'intérêt des individus
la droite qu'est ce que c'est ce sont
plutôt les gens qui pensent à l'intérêt
du pays à dire la france alors
évidemment son conservateur ce qui
concerne la france à gauche on
s'intéresse à la france le 6 mai on
s'intéresse d'abord aux intérêts
particuliers
les gens qui par exemple possède de
quelques propriétés qui possède quelques
commerces même quelques financements
droite à droite vous savez ces intérêts
l'intérêt personnel
c'est toujours pour la droite à leurs
intellectuels doublement non pas des
patients bien bien ambitieuse et de
gauche
mais si vous voulez la droite la gauche
ont serré la voix de la gauche
la droite c'est l'intérêt par la ligue 1
c'est la marée personnel c'est le
monsieur vite qu'ils votent plus à
gauche au contraire cherchent à
défendent des petites gens cherchent à
cultiver défendre l'intérêt général
beaucoup de personnes prétendent pas
faire du baltic la firme mêmes n'ont pas
encore de tous pouvons alors que tout
est uni que politique et même je dirais
que ceux qui prétendent pas faire la
politique
ce sont ceux qui à l'occasion
d'élections municipales élections
cantonales élections législatives sont
les plus déterminés mais donc ils sont
mac est par exemple politique alors si
votre interlocuteur vous a fait une
chaleur vous pouvez conclure ce n'est
pas personne qui va se garent suite de
notre feuilleton qui nous rappellent
très brièvement le temps de demain que
je vous donnais en début de journal le
grand froid ne devrait plus exister que
dans l'extrême nord-est ailleurs il
courra beaucoup de doutes mais assez plu
à journal est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi au nom de
qui tu peux c'est la rose qui valent
entre à le dernier journal après les
dossiers de l'écran c'est à dire vers
23h30 avec martin à la réunion île
reparlera de ses cent mille médecins
contre la france bonne soirée à tous